the reason people are upset with the Resilient Jenkins videos
if you haven't seen it it is a mom of six
about to be seven showing the sleeping conditions of her children
where all six kids are sharing sleeping areas in the living room and kitchen
while the mom and dad get the bedroom
now I have never been in a place of poverty
I've never been in a place that I can speak to living in conditions like this
but one thing that I am seeing the most of is mothers being upset
because why are you in the bedroom with no kids sleeping with you
when all your kids are in the living room
if you're in a struggling situation and you have children
your children's needs have to come above yours
so the only issue I see is not that they're living in a one bedroom
is not the fact that they have a lot of kids
it's how they have allocated their sleeping arrangements
and their resources for those six kids
so although we don't wanna come from a place of judgement
of judging parents who are trying their best
I think everybody who does have kids
is getting a giant red flag
about how they've allocated the resources that they do have
in prioritizing the comfort of themselves over their children
especially when you look at the safety risks
of having kids adjacent to a kitchen area
with sharp objects especially young kids
for talking under five
as well as the open access to the outside
which is the front door parents ultimately have to take the back seat
when it comes to health and safety of their children it just is